[Music]
there is a bs theme preview
function
that like given that you don't already
have a shiny application
that you want to preview a theme for
um
you can give bs theme preview like if i
had this
if i already had in mind like a theme
that i wanted to use
um and didn't want to do the work of
actually like programming a shiny
app example
i can just save this theme here
and
use this bs
preview
give it a theme
and it will apply that theme to this
demo like shiny demo app
that kind of tries its best to stuff all
of like the core shiny ui stuff
that we support
into this example app so you can see
like how those styles would end up
affecting like slider input
and select ties input
and date input
um as well as things like you know
verbatim text output and like
all of the
sort of shiny widgets that
um
you may or may not be already used to
[Music]
and then it also at the same time
overlays this interactive
widget that i can drag around
and use to
make tweaks to the actual
um
theme settings
so i can change from like a
something closer to a black to something
closer to like an ice blue
theme
so it's got the two main background and
foreground colors it's also got the
ability to
um
use a bootswatch theme
if you want to
just be aware like if you use a
bootswatch theme
don't expect like the custom theming
options to always work super great
uh with it so
just want to set expectations there that
like just because of the way that
bootswatch is currently set up they
haven't like implemented those themes
well enough in mind to like allow you to
tweak them
um
in
ways that work as well as just using the
default bootstrap theme
so just
be aware of that
so you can change the main like
background foreground as well as you
know i could have a
different primary color here
that will change like tab set panel
uh things like check boxes and radio
buttons
slider inputs also you know
we try our best to kind of use those
like main semantics of bootstrap and
propagate them throughout all of the
widgets that we provide in
chinese um so yeah the main like color
uh boot swatch settings as well as fonts
and again this has integration with
google fonts where
uh i could
choose any
uh sans serif font that i wanted let's
choose something like
not sure how to pronounce this one but i
do like it montserrat
so i could change from prompt to
montserrat
oh and actually that might be a bug that
it seems to have gone back to my
original theme settings
um but
now you can see like at the top here and
on the tab set panels it's got a
slightly different looking font here
it also has thematic enabled so that we
can look at how
the theme would actually be propagated
to our plots
defaults settings as well
so i could again change to like a
blue color here
and that will just automatically kind of
propagate to
the r plot
same thing with like dt tables dt also
has some nice integration with bslib
where it
derives its
sort of accent colors and main colors
and fonts as well um all those styles
from
the bslifting
and then you know these are just some
other
things that we provide in shiny ui like
modals and progress bars
notifications
and then like the difference between you
know how the heading fonts would look
versus code and base font
um and then some other kind of more
low-level options for more advanced
theming so
if you could see my art console here
various
output that has been
uh essentially echoed as i made changes
to the theming application
and it should do a good job of keeping
track of just the changes that you've
made interactively
so like this captures the fact that i've
changed to a
you know more of a blue background and
foreground color as well as the maserat
font setting
and
it's not quite smart enough to know like
that
it should actually integrate this stuff
with the input theme that you've given
it so you will have to essentially like
copy this code here
and it does make the assumption that
your theme is named theme but
thankfully i've actually used the name
theme so i can just say
bs theme update this theme with these
new settings and now
you know if i
feed this into input again
[Music]
on the bsd preview
it will use the montserrat
settings
the bs theme preview is really nice if
you're like again you don't already have
a shiny app that you're using and you
want to like get a feel for
you know what colors and fonts you might
want to use in your future shiny app
but if you already have an existing
shiny app you can leverage that same
interactive theming widget
so if i already have
this um
navbar page here
i can
first let me actually
do more of a traditional looking setup
here's the server function
which has the input and output arguments
as well as session
and then
bslib has a function called vs steamer
that you can
call inside of your
server function
and
then it will overlay
that same interactive themer
on this particular shiny app
so now i could go in and do the same
thing to my
basic navbar page
and still get the same experience of
like the code being output to replicate
the changes
[Music]
and you don't necessarily like you just
need to call this once you don't need to
worry about like calling this in a
reactive context or anything like that
like if you want to do this just go to
the top of your server function
and
call this function once and then it will
just
overlay that and
you can also collapse it if you don't
actually really want to use it
and you want to like do some other stuff
with your shiny app you can can collapse
it and kind of get it out of your way
if you don't want it anymore
and yeah not only can you do this with
shiny but you can also do this with your
markdown documents
but there is it's a little bit more
tricky to figure out how to do that
in the sense that it requires two
different things
it requires you to add a
runtime
shiny to your markdown document because
really
we can't get
the full
features of this interactive theming
widget working without a shiny runtime
[Music]
and then as well
um sort of like in your setup chunk
uh
you want to call this bs themer
sort of like how you called to be a
steamer in the server function
you want to do the same thing
in code that's going to run
in a server context which i can't
remember
if that's
oh actually that did looks like that
worked so we got this original
example that we were working from and
now this interactive themer so if i
wanted to like
have a look at one of these pre-packaged
themes
say minty
i can see how that will look on my our
markdown document
unfortunately thematic won't
work if you're static statically
rendering these plots um so it doesn't
know that like by default they won't
know to like re-render itself when your
theme has changed
but you can make that work as well if
you
instead
dynamically render this through a render
plot
which now we can do because we have the
runtime shiny like we can render have
the ability to render our plots
dynamically
so if i
let's just make sure this works by
stopping and
running again
all right so it's
recognized the default theme but now if
i change to
minty
it will know to re-render itself with
those new
css settings essentially
[Music]